so there's not too many sort of preconceived ideas
no they're they're they're bonkers aren't they
they are they're absolutely mad the targaryens
they're a right old bunch and emotional they're
so emotional and they can't talk to each other
yeah they're quite across family deep down i
think they need a lot a great deal of therapy
they do group therapy yeah yeah family therapy
i think there are like two main things that makes
that make renera a character who interests me at
least she is both female and never expects to be
air that's never on the table and everything falls
apart the moment that she receives the inheritance
that um everyone looks for he's a slightly sort of
slight sort of different creature to most of
them i think alison starts off as rhaenyra's
best friend and daughter to the hand of the king
and she is a quite an anxious rule follower in
comparison to how free and mischievous rhaenyra
is game of thrones it was the world was so big and
you were outside of king's landing and outside of
the sort of central focus of the main family a lot
uh whereas this is a bit more sort of insular
i think and there are more dragons in it for
one thing i think kind of damon and um feminine
crazies are sort of one entity really they're
one spirits they're sort of avatars of one another
they're both just grumpy and moody so i do think
there's an app there's a kind of weird symbiotic
sort of molecular thing that goes on that show was
its own entity it was a cultural phenomenon in
many ways and it was its own independent thing
and this is a new independent thing and it's a
different story with different actors with sort of
different people making it with the same ambitions
but um it will be different but obviously the way
we're telling it is the is the bit we'd like to
keep secret and the sort of the elements of it
the bits of the story that we're focusing on and
the characters perspective because that's what's
sort of different from the book isn't it it's
the perspective of our show is slightly different
i mean there's a really lovely thing right in
terms of any relationship between this show and
game of thrones in the future is i think some of
the kind of historic events that we hear about in
thrones maybe a record gets set straight in house
of the dragon. Welcome back everyone this will be
my brand new game of thrones house of the dragon
trailer video there's a bunch of new easter eggs
that they drop they talk about their characters so
we'll break it all down i will be doing videos for
there are a ton of main characters but what i
would describe is the most important characters
for the story in the two different factions of
the dance of the dragons targaryen civil war
the blacks and the greens led by rhaenyra and
allison on both sides and just like matt smith
younger versions of characters i'll point that out
when we get to that part of the video a little bit
later but probably one of the biggest new things
that they released here is king jiharis the first
in his family during the great council in the
year 101 at harrenhal that's basically what's
happening here you're looking at king jahirus
the person who was king of westeros before
patty considines viserys the first targaryen
who you see in most of the other trailers
what's happening here is they're actually getting
ready for the great council to decide that viserys
the first targaryen is going to be the next king
because technically according to the rules of
succession that they had set up at the time he
was not meant to be the next in line but that's
why jahiris the first is sitting on a different
throne that's not the iron throne because they're
at harrenhal here you see it in the trailer it's
like a much bigger version of harrenhal that we
saw on the original main show just because cg
has gotten so much better since then but the
reason why they called the great council here
to decide who would be king jaharis's successor
is because his original heir prince eamon the
first targaryen had died and he didn't have a son
his oldest living heir was princess rhaenys this
character here she's about 27 28 in the books
when this is happening even though she looks
a little bit older in this picture but by this
point in her life she's already been married to
cordless valerian the sea snake for a while he's
meant to be one of the wealthiest people in the
kingdom next to the throne the way he talks about
his character he's kind of like a tywin lannister
type of person like when you talk about lannisters
always paying their deaths lannisters being very
rich during the original series at this point in
history corliss velaryon and his family are one
of the richest families in westeros the reason
why they all have white hair is because they also
descend from valyrian blood they're a vassal house
of house targaryen so they also share the same
dna but they don't all ride dragons the same way
that the targaryens do so for instance because
rhaenys is a targaryen she has her own dragon
but her husband who's a velaryon and has valyrian
blood does not have his own dragon but because the
crown prince died without a male heir the realm
freaked out and this is in 101 ac they called a
great council to decide who would be the next king
and when it was put to vote rhaenys said that she
was voted down i think it was 20 or 21 lords of
the six kingdoms in dorne that voted her down
and voted instead that viserys the first targaryen
become the next king who was the brother of the
previous heir the younger son of jiharis the first
in the previous trailers you actually saw an older
version of rainey's basically telling the younger
rhaenyra about what had happened because younger
rhaenyra almost goes through the exact same thing
that leads to the actual targaryen civil war the
dance of the dragons so they're basically giving
us all this backstory to explain oh we've already
been through this once before and this is what
happened and this is why it's happening again
houses of westeros on it just to hammer home the
idea that they all swear fealty to her and support
her claim to the iron throne but what happens
is a little while after this the king winds up
getting remarried to her best friend growing up at
court who's also much younger and she bears him a
son that's where you get to the start of the dance
of the dragons because the new queen alicent says
that her son has rights to the iron throne and
her claim is better than rhaenyra's claim to the
iron throne right after the lords of the realm had
basically sworn filthy to her supporting her claim
all the great houses of westeros didn't split
into the different factions of the civil war
the blacks and the greens until after a great
tournament to celebrate the fifth anniversary
of the king's remarriage to allison and the reason
why they called them the blacks and the greens is
because princess rhaenyra and queen allison came
to the tourney wearing a black gown and a green
gown but remember this is the younger versions of
the characters so like the actual targaryen civil
war the dance of the dragons didn't start till a
little bit later so it took a while for this to
all spin up behind the scenes but that's what
matt smith is talking about when he says that
they tell the story in a very different kind of
way than they told the story from the original
game of thrones show the funny thing too is that
rhaenyra and alison both named their eventual sons
who became heirs to the iron throne at different
points in the timeline aegon aegon was a very
aegon the conqueror but that's why there's so
many dragons and all the dragons on the show
are so big so much bigger than daenerys dragons
because this is still relatively during the height
of the targaryens power in westeros and just for
reference jon snow would have been aegon vi had he
have actually taken the iron throne but all this
footage of damon targaryen is of younger damon
targaryen getting a version of dark's sister the
valyrian blade and using it with his dragon scale
armor remember rhaegar was supposed to wear a suit
of armor that looked kind of like this too later
in the timeline damon is called the rogue prince
just because he's such a hothead and he usually
is on the outs with his brother viserys the first
targaryen the current reigning king like you see
him getting dragged in by the kingsguard here
most of his time is spent scheming and plotting
finding a way to become the next heir to the iron
throne and a lot of that gets tied in with what's
happening with the dance of the dragons we make a
lot of jokes about how jaime lannister was like a
golden trash bag on the original game of thrones
show damon targaryen is actually the person who
created the gold cloaks the city watch of king's
landing that's why you see him in the scene here
wearing the gold cloak because this is like the
first time that that happened you could think
of him as kind of like the glorious golden
trash bag of the house of the dragon series
there's a scene of him in the trailers where you
see the king's guard in otto hightower the hand of
the king trying to take the dragon egg from him
you see him earlier in this scene grabbing the
actual dragon egg before the king's garden found
him i believe what was happening here is that
earlier in the timeline he had sired a bastard and
because the bastard was born to his bloodline and
was born with the dragon rider gene he was trying
to give him a dragon egg so that when his bastard
grew of age he could eventually ride a dragon
too but one of the crazier things about the
targaryen family is the way that they treat their
dragon eggs like they're more precious than gold
so for instance viserys the first targaryen
played by patty constantine is supposed to be
a relatively decent person but when he finds out
that damon targaryen tried to steal a dragon egg
and give it to one of his bastards he said hell
no give the dragon egg back right now because
the whole idea is that the dragons have been the
key to targaryen power in westeros for hundreds of